this is the fourth of seven miguel rojas
leads the troops out onto the
look look out
maybe he actually just tripped going on
the field there not sure uh what
happened but he's in some pain right now
around second base
he just takes like a bad step right
there and stumbles
and he's shaking his right hand and that
was uh the hand he put down to brace
himself
and he's in pain right now he uh he's
trying to shake it out he said right
there is where he's pointing towards
somewhere he just took a a bad step
that's his uh his right hand so his
throwing hand
certainly something to monitor here jose
uranya makes his second start this year
this is sixth big league season outside
ball four that'll load the bases up
for dd gregorius didi is two for nine
with a double and that one is hit high
and deep to right field going back out
at his joyce it is gone
a grand slam for dede
and the phillies jump out to a four
nothing lead here at the top of the
first inning boy that ball was crushed
take advantage of your opponent's
weaknesses you had the air the two walks
and the bad 002 pitch and dede goes up
top right header spencer howard who's
got a nice four-run lead to work with
second pick for the phillies in the 2017
draft 45th overall and the pitch all the
way swings and drives it the other way
caught by segura leaning to his left he
throws back to first and they got him
what a play by gene segura in the hole
at second base gene segural with an
amazing catch and throw back to first
to doubled off dickerson
john's pull to bryce harper
and again the payoff pitch opposite way
that's well hit going back on it is
dickerson back to the wall it is gone
an opposite field home run for bryce
harper
it's his eighth of the year
it was a long time coming and the
phillies are on top five to nothing and
you're absolutely right that is a really
good sign bryce using the left side of
the diamond with some thunder told you
there were some numbers
zagular gets the first hit of the night
for the marlins good piece of hitting on
a 94 mile an hour fastball rockets it
into right field so the marlins will
have two aboard with
two outs this is when the offense starts
to come to life see if they can do
something here in the fourth three and
two andy with the drive out to left that
is back that is gone
three run over for brian anderson
more magic with two outs and anderson
makes it a 5-3 game without it do any
running or
he has thrown
there's a ground ball base hit for
harper up the middle
things will normalize a lead off single
here in the fifth
opposite way and a base hit to left
center field real muto around second on
his way to third he'll get there as the
throw goes to second base
first and third one out
attack one on here gene
here the dirt gets away and that's going
to bring real mutual home and up to
second base goes deedee
and it's now 6-3 phillips
well pitch on the first off
and he rips that one down the line
inside it and fair aguilar around third
he'll score brinson racing to second
takes a turn
and he'll get back to the bag and rbi
double for louis brinson
six to four
there's an appreciation there's a flare
out to right field it'll be another base
hit for bowm segura is on his way to
third the throw is not in time
i think he's surprised brinson and these
are the little things gene not
hesitating at all you're absolutely
right that took princeton by surprise
because he's got a strong enough arm
and again
three run lead definitely misses him
that is awesome
that's a great angle
so they're on the corners of aggressive
base running there by gene segura
and adam hazley
is due up that one's up the first base
line slowly runner coming home they
missed the tag
the run scores at 7-4 and hazley is safe
at first
very very sneaky
i said did you not see that
i don't think he was that far out
yeah i don't think he's that far out
you're allowed three feet
well he's a little farther there but
that's okay
and this one to right and gonna be extra
bases it'll get all the way to the wall
harper though well i thought it'd be
extra bases then i thought better of
that because harper has such a strong
arm and in front of home plate rail muto
pounces spins throws and it goes up the
right field line cooper's going to come
around to score jazz being held
and on a ball that goes about 30 feet up
the line the marlins get a run and two
in scoring position and hoskins coming
up lame at first yeah hoskins lost his
glove literally trying to catch the
throw from jt as dickerson was running
down the line there was a bit of a
collision
these extra hits like late in the game
that one's pulled to right field
personality hits or something
it's going to be another double for
bryce
as he gets in standing
down to left center field that'll be in
for a base hit harper's around third
heading for home dede is on his way to
third it'll be an rbi double
when gene comes through with his second
hit of the night it's 8-5 phillies not a
more gratifying feeling in the world
right there tom
oh
you don't want to face td you want to
face me okay
i'll show you there's a swing of the
ground ball deep short diving chism
can't get it it deflects off his glove
and goes out towards the left field line
one run has scored they're going to give
the stop sign at third to segura he went
hard around the bag baum is in its
second it's nine to five phillies garlic
is the hitter with the bases loaded
and he pulls that one down the left
field line that's a fair ball going to
the corner and the phillies are busted
this baby wide open it's going to be a
bases clearing double for kyle garlick
and the phillies lead it 12-5
on 3-1 aguilar hits a high fly ball left
center field and deep garlic back on the
track at the wall can't get it home run
jesus aguilar his first of the season
here at marlins park and it's 12-6
out towards shortstop there's one
and two double play ends the ball game
and the phillies win it by a final score
of 12-6 they've evened up this series at
two wins a piece